-As the committee investigating
the coup attempt on January 6th
continues to reveal new evidence
of a coordinated criminal plot
by Donald Trump
to overthrow American democracy,
Trump is responding
by suggesting
he might pardon
the January 6th defendants,
if he gets reelected in 2024.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
The reason these hearings
are important is very simple --
this wasn't a one-off
and Trump hasn't forgotten.
If he gets the chance,
he's going to finish the job.
And this is one
of the rare times
you can say that about Trump.
He's not exactly a closer.
[ Laughter ]
I'm not sure he ever technically
finished any of his buildings.
[ Laughter ]
I'm pretty sure that,
instead of putting fire alarms
in his condos,
he just painted them on.
[ Laughter ]
But Trump has made it
abundantly clear
that he hasn't forgotten
about the 2020 election
and he hasn't let it go.
If he gets the chance,
he will absolutely finish
the coup he started
on January 6th,
as he made clear recently,
when he dangled the possibility
of pardoning defendants
in January 6th cases.
-Even while
January 6th defendants
are having their lives
totally destroyed
and being treated worse
than terrorists and murderers,
despite most being charged
with parading
through the Capitol.
Most people.
Should not be treated
the way they're being treated.
[ Laughter ]
And, if I become
president someday,
if I decide to do it,
I will be looking at them very,
very seriously for pardons.
Very, very seriously.
[ Cheering and applause ]
They've been treated
very unfairly.
Should I decide to do that.
-Trump is so bad at playing coy,
if he had a fan,
he'd cut a hole in it,
so you can still see his mouth.
[ Laughter and applause ]
He says,
"If I decide to do it,"
like he's threatening to streak
across the quad
after a frat party.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Trump ] I dare you guys
to join me.
If I decide to do it.
[ Laughter ]
"Donald, you're already naked."
[ As Trump ]
So be it!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Second,
when you say they were charged
with parading like that,
you make it sound
like they were on floats,
wearing sashes that said,
"Happy Insurrection Day."
[ Laughter ]
Yes, there is such a thing
as illegal parading,
or demonstrating in the Capitol,
and many people have been
charged with that,
but that's very different
from parading,
in the sense Trump seems
to be using it.
I mean, in New York, we have
parades like every day.
It's completely different.
Every time I get in a cab
and say,
I want to go to Midtown,
the cabbie says something like,
"Well, it's Luxembourgian
Independence Day,
so I got to take you
through Secaucus."
[ Laughter ]
The other day,
traffic was stopped
along Fifth Avenue
because there was a parade
for the
National Association
of Trombone Players
[ Laughter ]
Annual Trombone
Appreciation Day.
It was so annoying.
[ Laughter ]
Every time someone dropped
their ice cream cone,
you'd hear this --
[ Sad trombone ]
[ Laughter ]
In fact, contrary to Trump,
several members
of right-wing groups
and militias
have been charged
with seditious conspiracy.
In fact, we learned
from the committee last week
the rioters got within 40 feet
of Vice President Mike Pence
and were absolutely willing
to do physical harm to Pence,
if they had the chance.
-Vice President Pence
and his team,
ultimately, were led
to a secure location,
where they stayed for the next
four and a half hours...
...barely missing rioters
a few feet away.
-Approximately 40 feet.
That's all there was,
40 feet between
the vice president and the mob.
Make no mistake
about the fact
that the vice president's life
was in danger.
A recent court filing by the
Department of Justice explains
that a confidential informant
from the Proud Boys
told the FBI the Proud Boys
would've killed Mike Pence,
if given a chance.
-One thing we're learning
from this investigation is
that the coup
was much more sinister
than that pic of the dude
jacking the podium.
[ Laughter ]
If the rioters had the chance,
they would've done
the same thing to Mike Pence.
[ Laughter ]
You know, the guy
who took the podium
probably thought he had Pence.
You were supposed
to grab the VP!
"This has the same charisma!"
[ Laughter ]
I feel like, as a nation,
we haven't all fully appreciated
the degree
to which the president
basically almost got
the vice president killed.
That feels like something you
only read about
in history books,
like the Burr-Hamilton Duel.
Of course,
if Trump and Pence ever dueled,
only one thing
would be certain --
Trump ain't doing
the full ten paces.
[ Laughter ]
[ As Pence ]
Now, before we do this,
Mr. President,
I would like your assurances
that we are agreed on the rules.
[ As Trump ]
Absolutely, Mike, ten passes.
Maybe eight, but at least five.
[ Laughter ]
With that said --
With that said, Mike,
I have big paces,
so three of mine are probably
worth ten of your tiny paces.
[ Laughter ]
Everyone seems to have moved on
from the threat to Pence,
and that includes Pence himself,
who also seems to not be holding
a grudge against Trump
for, you know,
almost getting him killed.
Just a week ago,
Pence bragged about his record
in the Trump administration,
tweeting...
Pence is like that clueless guy
you date in college
who could not understand
that you were dumping him.
[ Laughter ]
We should see other people.
"I see other people
all the time.
Look, there's one.
Alright, pick you up at 8:00."
No, dude, we're over.
"Over the moon about this
perfect relationship."
[ Laughter ]
I'm breaking up with you.
"I've been told
I break people up
with my knock-knock jokes."
[ Laughter ]
So it's pretty clear
that Trump was,
at the very least, indifferent
as to whether he had put
his own vice president
in physical danger
and it's also clear
Trump sicced the mob on Pence
for not following through
on something
even Trump himself
knew was illegal.
Last week, the committee
provided new evidence
that Trump and his pro-coup
lawyer, John Eastman,
who laid out a detailed plan
for how Pence could overturn
the election,
knew the plan was
against the law
when they tried to get Pence
to do it.
In fact, toward the end
of Trump's presidency,
Eastman even sent an email
to Rudy Giuliani,
casually suggesting that maybe
Trump should pardon Eastman.
-Dr. Eastman emailed
Rudy Giuliani
and requested
that he be included
on a list
of potential recipients
of a presidential pardon.
Dr. Eastman's email stated...
I've decided that I should be
on the pardon list
-He's like a guy walking
up to the bouncer at a club
by himself, trying to get in.
"I've decided I should be
on the VIP list."
[ Laughter ]
[ Italian accent ] Move.
Move out of the way,
or I'm going to squeeze
your head like a grape.
Right this way, ladies.
[ Laughter ]
Also, I love how he phrased it,
like he had just sort of
casually thought about a pardon,
like it was a fun idea,
and not that it was starting
to dawn on him
that he was breaking the law
and might go to prison.
He's like a guy on the phone
with his insurance agent
while you can hear the sound
of fire trucks
in the background.
"Yeah, hey, a few months ago,
you mentioned fire insurance
[ Laughter ]
and I was thinking about it
during our fireworks-themed
gender reveal party
[ Laughter ]
and maybe I should --
yeah, maybe I should get that.
[ Laughter ]
And I guess it makes sense
that, if you're looking
for the pardon list,
you'd email Rudy Giuliani.
He's definitely the guy
who came up with the idea
of a pardon list.
[ Laughter ]
The pardon list is probably
just every possible version
of his own name written on the
back of a steakhouse napkin.
[ Laughter ]
Because even Rudy,
who we tend to think of
as a delusional,
bumbling doofus,
due to, you know...
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, I know we use
that picture a lot,
but here's the deal --
you keep laughing at it,
we're going to keep using it.
[ Laughter ]
Even Rudy
apparently knew that the whole
scheme was illegal.
That's according
to a deposition broadcast
by the committee last week
from former Trump White House
lawyer Eric Herschmann.
Herschmann said he had told
Eastman that his plan was insane
and that, later,
Rudy had agreed with Herschmann
that the plan was illegal.
-The president's own lead
outside counsel, Rudy Giuliani,
also seemed to concede
that the vice president
did not have the authority
to decide the outcome
of the election
or send it back to the states.
Here's what White House attorney
Eric Herschmann said
about his call
with Mayor Giuliani
on the morning of the 6th.
-The morning of January 6th,
he called me
out of the blue, right?
And I was like getting dressed.
And we had
an intellectual discussion
about Eastman's --
I don't know if it's Eastman's
theory per se,
but the VP's role.
And,
you know, he was asking me
my view, analysis,
and then the practical
implications of it.
And, when we finished, he said,
"I believe that, you know,
you're probably right."
-First of all,
I doubt it was truly
an intellectual discussion,
if Rudy was involved.
[ Laughter ]
Saying you had an intellectual
discussion with Rudy Giuliani
is like saying you played chess
with a horse.
[ Laughter ]
Second, it's incredible to me
that even Rudy knew
it was a crazy and bad idea.
Rudy.
That's how you know your plan is
truly [bleep] insane.
[ Laughter ]
This is a guy who,
while under multiple
investigations,
thought it was a good idea
to do a video
using an Abraham Lincoln filter.
[ Laughter ]
That same guy looked
at John Eastman's plan and said,
"I...don't know."
[ Laughter ]
The January 6th hearings
have revealed a ton
of incriminating new details,
so far, including the fact
that the attempted coup was
a lot more sinister
and a lot more sophisticated
than previously known.
Even Trump and his cronies
knew it was illegal.
They clearly
had criminal intent.
Now, Trump is
basically admitting
that he'll do it again,
if he gets the opportunity.
He's confessing in advance.
It's like he's writing his own
version of that book by O.J.,
called, "If I Did It,"
except Trump's is called...
-If I decide to do it.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.